ou des amis qui sont devenus amis et
juste qui ont pas voulu autre chose avec
toi les deux
et des ex qui sont devenus des amis et
j'ai des amis garçons voilà
sûrement jamais rien voilà il voulait
pas ou c'est tout de suite une barrière
voilà donc d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'amitié entre garçon et fille pour les
hétéros ou garçon pour les homos ça
existe s'il y a pas d'attirance sexuelle
ça existe si l'autre te plaît pas
physiquement c'est ça tu pourras
alors j'adore Benjamin j'adore
tu peux pas être ami avec un homme que
tu as envie de pécho il a raison
tu peux pas être ami avec un mec ou une
meuf que tu as envie de pécho tu vois
être ami avec toutes les filles sur ce
plateau
est-ce que tu pourrais être ami avec
Cyril par exemple
toi tu penses qu'à fourrer quelque chose
non mais franchement non mais sans
déconner
ils sont dégueulasses soit sur un ou
deux qui me plaisait pas et ceux qui me
plaisaient en général on se rencontrera
en boîte on a d'abord couché ensemble
d'accord et puis on a vu que c'était ça
le faisait pas et ça s'est transformé en
amitié ben je me demande si tu sais pas
ce que devrait faire dans l'émission
pour les amis non alors quand les quand
le champagne coulé à flot c'est du don
Pérignon
[Rires]
est-ce que tu as eu des amis il y a une
époque beaucoup plus d'amis
qu'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que tu as une anecdote nous
raconte
des soirées les gens viennent chez vous
et cetera ils sont contents de venir
mais après ils viennent beaucoup moins
quand les gens viennent moins bah oui
beaucoup beaucoup arrête tu as moins
d'amis qu'avant ah oui quand vous avez
du pâté NAF au lieu d'avoir du foie gras
forcément ça leur plaît moi ah ouais
ouais ouais tu as senti que les mecs
évidemment vous le sentez forcément le
mois d'amis
d'avoir une cour
alors tu vas nous en parler dans un
instant pour revenir sur toi tu peux
mettre ta dévisser toi ouais de ouf
quand tu dévisses qu'est-ce qui se passe
bah tu dévisses
c'est compliqué et ça ne s'arrête pas ça
ne s'arrête pas
vous aimez bien vous aimez bien Warren
beatti il ressemble à une Betty
tu ressembles à avoir une bêtise l'homme
aux 1000 femmes
les mec vous allez encore croire
benjamino
encore essayer de nous faire croire il y
a deux jours qu'il avait pas une fausse
poitrine non mais les gars
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que j'ai beaucoup d'amis oui
j'ai beaucoup d'amis parce que pour moi
l'amitié c'est très important
[Applaudissements]
l'amitié et l'amour c'est très important
et je pense que la guerre c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'horrible et j'aimerais
bien travailler en communication qu'elle
j'aime beaucoup le relation avec les
diverses personnes et j'aime au voyage
puisque j'ai fait un BTS tourisme
[Applaudissements]
quand j'aime des personnes je leur donne
vraiment tout mon cœur et donc du coup
mes copains ils sont très contents mais
que pas mes copines on est vraiment j'ai
beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup d'amis j'ai
presque même beaucoup de meilleurs amis
j'en ai beaucoup je pense que et des
hommes aussi beaucoup
non mais tu crois réveille-toi tu crois
qu'il y a vraiment des mecs que tu vas
te faire chier
c'est toujours tous les coachs
mais tous tous tous je crois tu te rends
pas compte aujourd'hui
sur l'hexagone
avec toi
non non parce que je suis je suis une
bonne pote en fait je suis un peu je
suis un peu masculine dans ma relation
avec mes copains et donc du coup on peut
sortir on peut faire la fête il me
confie leur truc et sans jugement et
voilà voilà on peut tout faire et avec
mes copines aussi on est on fait des
trucs voilà de filles plus spirituelles
je sais pas mais une dizaine pote ouais
pote
mecs par exemple
c'est que dans tous mes amis donc dans
les dizaines de potes que j'ai c'est
vrai que ils ont tous flanché à un
moment tout ça chacun
passé une soirée c'est ton pote tout ça
et tout et il arrive devant la maison
je vous dis un truc qui ne trompe pas
quand la meuf prépare ses clés bien
avant de sortir de la voiture tu sais
que tu es mort tu sais que tu ne la
pécheras pas ça c'est un truc c'est
officiel c'est direct si la meuf elle
prend ses clés déjà et à longtemps avant
que tu sois arrivé en bas de chez elle
carlette mon frère
ça veut dire c'est mort n'essaye rien
non seulement tu vas prendre une banane
et en plus tu vas faire la route tout
seul et là tu vas ressasser pourquoi
j'ai fait ça et j'aurais dû faire ça
je connais le chemin du retour quand tu
as pris une banane frère
même si tu habites à 2 km c'est comme si
tu faisais 1000 km en voiture
tu crois qu'il y a des péages et tout
sur la tête de ma mère tu te dis
pourquoi j'aurais peut-être dû le faire
au moment quand elle est rentrée dans la
voiture pourquoi j'ai peut-être ouais
peut-être elle a pas vu que je voulais
la pécho en fait peut-être faut que je
la rappelle et là tu envoies un texto
comment moi WhatsApp c'est pas du tout
ce que tu crois
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de coeurs des choses comme ça
c'est quoi
ça commence à envoyer ça alors je disais
il y a une technique claire déjà il y a
un truc clair c'est que si la jeune
fille avec qui vous êtes
sort ses clés quand vous la ramenez bien
avant d'arriver chez elle c'est mort ne
tentez rien vous savez que vous allez
prendre la banane c'est comment je
cherchais dans ce sac elle prend ses
clés moi je me rappelle j'ai ramené
Daniel un jour
elle a mis une heure à chercher ses clés
j'ai oublié les clés elle a dû dormir à
la maison voilà sur le lit superposé
elle était en haut j'étais en bas et je
peux vous dire que j'avais une très
belle vie
je vous le dis on connaît tous ce moment
où tu es sur une meuf depuis longtemps
ça fait des semaines et des semaines que
tu es sur le bail tu arrives et tu sais
que tu vas l'avoir un soir et tu essaies
souvent de la pécho en bas de chez elle
c'est une erreur et je le dis je le dis
franchement si vous êtes sur un bail
depuis longtemps et que vous êtes sur la
soirée où ça doit se décanter tenter
tout de suite n'allez pas payer le
restaurant après tout ça
d'accord
vous dites alors je vous le dis à une
petite technique tu es déjà le cauchemar
tu vois le petit smack quand elle arrive
tu vois si tu vois que déjà elle fait
comment
là déjà frère je te dis c'est chaud
c'est chaud moi je vais vous dire là je
vais vous raconter une anecdote donc je
ne suis pas fier encore une fois de plus
mon père avait une Audi il était
persuadé que c'était la voiture de
l'année elle avait 120 000 km elle avait
les sièges au range mon frère une archum
de ouf il la mettait dans un garage à
200 mètres de chez moi je le dis ne le
fait pas
qu'est-ce que je faisais un jour j'ai
rendez-vous avec des meufs moi
j'habitais au lilas il est moche habiter
genre dans le 16e c'est genre tu vois
les meufs
voilà tu vois fraîche tu vois qui ont
l'habitude
mon frère je mets mon plus beau jogging
je suis frais
ce pote à moi devenir avec moi il y
avait Sofiane et Olivier on y commence
on est dans la voiture on met je danse
le mia
j'ai volé la voiture de mon daron je
pars avec l'Audi comme ça je pars des
Lilas mon frère je suis en expédition je
croyais que je partais en Algérie
j'avais mis des affaires sur la galerie
et tout sur la tête de ma mère frère
j'avais ramené genre de tout de l'eau
autour je croyais qu'on partait en
expédition on parlait 3 des Lilas quand
même on a rendez-vous avec des meufs du
16e
genre un copain nous a dit ouais truc
chez les copines elles sont sympathiques
voilà voyez ça elle nous avait jamais vu
on arrive et tout je vais les chercher
c'est à côté de l'étoile genre les meufs
elle descendre frère on dirait qu'elle
allait à la marmite va du petit homme
selem
elle sorte mon frère elle voit la
voiture déjà l'audiboard avec les sièges
orange
avec à fond en boucle je danse le mien
et la maman
une bagarre
et là on les amène il y avait un
restaurant qui s'appelait le Chicago
Pizza Paï c'était des pizzas
avec des pizzas
rue de Richard Berry et donc là on y va
avec les trois meufs je suis avec les
trois copains et là frère on est en
train de manger les pizzas on commence
les pizzas et elle se démonte elle
démonte et tout frère nous on vous dit à
trois on avait 12 balles
on était déjà comme as et on se dit
donc là les meufs j'arrive je suis avec
mes copains je leur dis des gars je sens
qu'un je le sens pas c'est bizarre elles
nous ont pas parlé tout le trajet
au restaurant nous parle pas beaucoup ça
sent la patate je vous dis les gars moi
je paye pas je m'en bats les steaks je
paye pas mon
truc dis-moi je paye pas les couilles je
vais aux toilettes et je dis ok voilà
réunion les gars moi je m'en bats les
réunion je paye pas
je connais ça commence à prendre des
décès et tout pour dire
[Rires]
je suis en haut mon frère je sais que
vas-y sinon là la semaine là c'est je
suis mort en fin de semaine j'ai plus 1
€, je suis mort donc là qu'est-ce que je
fais je n'y avais pas tu veux faire un
truc là je vais quand même je veux que
ça soit et là je fais genre je fais
genre attendez je vais voir et tout je
sens et là je suis rien je fais comme
d'habitude je fais les gars il y a une
embrouille la voiture on est en train
d'enlever la voiture de mon daron
l'Audi là on part on s'est sauvé on a
pris le lit on est retourné au Lidl
pizza on a été manger chez Pizza Hut mon
frère
[Applaudissements]
de ma vie donc je te dis Delphine pour
revenir à toi c'est sûr que 10 potes
vous les pécho évidemment et je peux
vous dire et le trajet qu'on t'a pris
une banane en plus avec une meuf sur
laquelle tu es depuis longtemps le
trajet mon frère est à chaque fois que
tu es comme ça dans la voiture et tu
laisses la radio je pense qu'il y a et
là tu as toujours une musique genre
parce que tu sais que ça commence à
taper alors alors tu l'as péché non je
te rappelle
tu connais ou pas alors alors tu
l'appelles je sais pas si je te rappelle
toi
je me suis vénère chaud avec des potes
vas-y qu'est-ce que tu me casses les
couilles là vas-y tu m'appelles pour ça
toi je suis dans le travail moi de ma
paix pour des meufs toi vas-y m'appelles
plus
ça m'est arrivé ça m'arrive ça m'arrive
je connais voilà donc elle fine tes
potes ils ont vécu ça
écoute voilà on reste amis on est bon
pote et tout ça
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire frère c'est vrai mais
arrêtez de faire la meuf elle te dit tu
restes tu la vois à chaque fois et tu
dois qu'il arrive je vais pas la pêche
et tu vois des autres mecs qui la Chine
tu vois et tout tu vois et tu défends
les mains pas ouf
c'est un camion
je trouve pas
le trou pas ouf de ouf et en plus les
amis de Delphine ils ont toujours
l'espoir bah bien sûr enlève les soins
des petites rechutes
ou des choses comme ça mais vu que moi
je suis généralement souvent en couple
bah du coup j'ai toujours la bonne
excuse de dire ben non on est amis parce
que j'ai tu voilà je suis pas dispo je
suis pas dispo donc quel âge tes amis
c'est très varié je crois que tu veux te
positionner
franchement c'est exactement ça c'est un
truc bien sûr qu'il y a des rechutes
je suis perdu